Speaker 1: You knew they were going to do
it. You knew that when Joe Biden got COVID,
the anti-vax was going to come out of the
woodwork. The glee about Biden having COVID was
going to come out of the woodwork and conspiracy
theories were going to come out of the woodwork.
And we have all of it for you today. Let's start
with a Fox News contributor saying that Joe Biden
got COVID as karma for pretending to have cancer.
Now, this is stupid for two reasons. Number one,
Biden didn't pretend to have cancer.
And number two. Biden already had COVID
before he made the cancer gaffe by all reasonable
understandings of the incubation period of COVID.
So let's look at this clip and then discuss.
Speaker 2: I hate to be that annoyingly optimistic
guy, but there's no better time in the world to
be sick than right now, today, right in history,
because we have more opportunity to heal from
it now and we've ever had. And there's no
better place than probably the White House to be
when you get sick and we have all the resources
in front of you. My experience, we covered the
twice the two times I've had it the first time,
had a little bit of a fever. At the same time,
I had a cold. And I think that's what everyone
has been saying over and over again. So I hope.
Speaker 1: Well, not everyone, not the million
people that died, but yes, many, many, many
people have mild symptoms. And that's true.
Speaker 2: And pray that that's what the president
experiences. I don't want any bad health on him. I
think life comes at you fast. I think when you're
pretending to have cancer one day and you've got
cold the next, you might want to recalibrate how
you treat things and how you talk. But I'm not
going to, you know, I don't wish bad luck on him
and I'm not going to say that. But that's reason
why. It's just maybe it's a good opportunity
from that reality check. I get so frustrated with
these politicians that think they have to connect
themselves to every dire thing that happens in an
Americans life. And I think President Biden,
his last statement on cancer, your status is
proof of that, that politicians have taken that
too far. So what I hope is he recovers fast. It
doesn't hurt him that well that much at all.
And then when he recovers, he reconsiders,
you know, just how politicians work on
stuff like this because saying he had cancer
the way he did and backtracking it the way they
did as that's karma, man. You don't want to.
Speaker 1: It's karma, man. He just
misspoke, guys. I mean, this is very,
very stupid. As a reminder, yesterday
when speaking, Joe Biden talked about
have cancer rather than had cancer. He's
not pretending to have cancer. I mean,
to pretend to have cancer, you'd have
to be able to say, I have this type
of cancer and it's a lie. He just misspoke.
Speaker 2: My mother drove us and rather than
us to be able to walk and guess what? The first
frost. You know what was happening. You had to
put on your windshield wipers to get literally the
oil slick off the window. That's why I had so damn
many other people. I grew up having cancer.
And why can't for the longest time. Delaware
had the highest cancer rate in the nation.
Speaker 1: All right, so he just misspoke.
And then the other thing, that it's some kind
of karma because Biden pretended to have cancer.
Typically, it's at least two days of incubation
with COVID. And it was announced very early
Thursday morning. Biden making the cancer
gaffe on Wednesday afternoon. The idea that
the timing even works doesn't work. These
people are very, very strange and they
have extraordinarily bizarre ideas, but not as
bizarre as the ones I'm going to show you next.